let's talk sitcoms
it's short for situational communism and
a major tool of hollywood's liberal
brainwashing machine
like how Jerry Seinfeld wants us to hate
the Soup Nazi when we know for a fact
there were good soup people on both soup
sides but this week we real Americans
had a major win in the sitcom world with
the premiere of a newly rebooted rosanna
rosanna a show about a blue-collar Trump
voter who battles with her aunt Aoife
Soros funded abortion craze Clinton ista
sister I assume I didn't watch it but
America did in fact 18 million viewers
tune in on Tuesday night and it's all
anybody could talk about anybody being
everybody on Fox News the Roseanne
reboot generated an enormous rating 18
million Americans watched the show last
night
funny what can happen when Hollywood
makes programming that's not
condescending toward half the country
sorry stormy this other Trump woman
trounced your interview in the key demo
this thing exploded and it exploded
because it's a safe fun place for people
to have a political discussion yes safe
places finally a place where you can go
to be sheltered from liberal snowflakes
demanding their safe spaces and
conservatives can relate to Roseanne in
real life she's a down-to-earth Trump
supporter she gets middle America she's
even a farmer or more specifically the
humble owner of a million-dollar
macadamia nut plantation in Hawaii
she's the salted nuts of the earth I've
always said representation matters and
finally Trump voters have it Roseanne is
our Black Panther
and our Wakanda is Lanford Illinois but
while wakanda's economy is based around
futuristic technology lanford's economy
is based around a Sam's Club and a
shuttered Sears where squirrels have sex
see what kind of fans get to do that
cool ex thing but Lanford fans get to do
this yeah way cooler so you hear that
what's that noise I'll tell you what it
is it's the million of boots of
Hollywood's stampeding to replicate
Roseanne's success and leading the
charge
our chief opportunists Aaron Jackson and
Josh this opens a huge lane for us it's
so nice to see familiar TV faces a
little bit older a little bit wiser and
a little bit more reflecting back
exactly what I believe at me we want a
Hollywood to know that we are full of
ideas for hot reboots that are topical
political topical and right-leaning
yeah NBC could bring back Seinfeld
exactly but Jerry and George moved away
and Elaine is married and Christian and
quiet Yeah right so now most of the show
is just Kramer improvising slurs to
people on the street yeah oh I would
love to see perfect strangers come back
yes but it's all about cousin Larry now
because Balki has been deported so much
better okay The Jeffersons only this
time they're moving on down yeah they're
just a lot more comfortable then yeah
they fit in okay The Cosby Show it's the
same show we just know what we know now
okay so now I'm just I'm spitballing
how about Malcolm right-of-center or a
fake news radio alternative facts of
life ideally we could get Kelly and
Conway to star fingers cross or or Louie
it's the same show we just know what we
know now
clarissa has things explained to her by
her male boss the premise alone is crazy
a woman with a job be the liberal Slayer
you know angel we can leave alone angel
is perfect perfect David Spade do just
shoot them as a stand-your-ground show
who or boy meets world rejects world
builds wall abstinence in the city
imagine the fancy mocktails ow it's the
same show we just know what we know now
but what do we know now Oh
Jordan just wait that one's coming and
it's gonna make Harvey Weinstein look
like mr. Rogers Jesus I gotta say I love
this because right now the Wright has
nothing but once we're dominant in
popular culture other media doors will
open we can get a news channel that
caters to us then we can mobilize the
voters and take control of state houses
then before you know it most governor's
will be Republicans and then we can work
to take control of Congress and even the
executive branch someday Jordan yes
someday thanks guys go make Hollywood
great again alright Josh and Aaron
opposition you can feel it you can feel
it the future looks bright and very
similar to 1988
roseann success is clearly the most
important story of the week it's why the
president the United States personally
called Rose Ann to congratulate her on
her huge ratings win and he should gain
nose game but of course the left has its
priorities flipped and what's Trump to
address more pressing issues like the
March for our lives the high number of
porn stars currently suing him whether
we should have a NASA
and then there's the recent police
shooting of an unarmed 22 year old black
man Stefan Clark who was shot multiple
times at his grandmother's backyard
while holding a cell phone but there's a
very good reason why Trump's not talking
about that this is something that is a
local matter and that's something that
we feel should be left up to the local
authorities at this point in time
exactly exactly
just leave it to the local authorities
the police are the best people to deal
with this particular police shooting
they were there it's like they're always
there and what the left doesn't get is
that President Trump called Rose Ann
because she had huge ratings this police
shooting just didn't make enough noise
probably because the cops had muted
their body cameras so let's leave this
local story to the local authorities the
president has television to watch
[Music]